your customers will never love your
company until your employees love it
first
so if you have good leadership and you
have a healthy culture yes be customer
obsessed absolutely um
but if you have a weak culture and you
have toxic leaders
no amount of yelling at people to be
customer obsessed will ever change
anything um so so to truly be customer
focused the irony is to truly have
customer centricity the irony is is you
actually uh uh care about your people
leadership can care about the people and
the front line people care about the
leaders i care about the customers i
mean you know
that's the hierarchy again it's who do
you touch leadership doesn't interact
with a client or a customer ever or
rarely and so focus on the people you
interact with which is your people
leadership is responsible for building
the culture get that right and the and
the front line staff the people who are
uh customer contact they focus on the
customer if you get that wrong
uh then what happens is you create a
culture where
customer facing
team members
are actually scared of doing things to
protect themselves from their own
leaders i'll give you example if you
have a culture where it's completely
normal
for people to send a cya email after
every decision they make right like a
cover your ass email
um see seeing everybody just in case
something goes wrong you know that is a
sign that people are taking time and
energy away from doing things for the
customer to protect themselves from
their own leaders you know if it is
standard practice in the company where
everybody keeps a folder of all the good
things they've ever done you know just
in case you need it it's a sign that
people are taking time and energy away
from their day
away from taking care of a customer to
protect themselves from their own
company and that's what i mean which is
when you have strong leadership where
people feel
psychologically safe at work
all of that energy all of that ingenuity
all of that uh innovative ideas goes in
the place we want it to go which is to
the customer